la cour pénale internationale se dit
compétente pour juger des crimes commis
dans les territoires palestiniens
occupés ici annonce hier soir de la cour
qui siège à la haye aux pays-bas
l'instance précise que cette décision ne
préjuge en aucun cas de la question des
frontières
elle pourrait toutefois ouvrir la voie à
une enquête pour crimes de guerre une
opération saluée par les autorités
palestiniennes et dénoncé par israël
cette décision est une victoire pour la
justice et l'humanité pour les valeurs
de vérité d'équité de liberté et pour le
sang des victimes et de leurs familles
aujourd'hui le tribunal a une nouvelle
fois prouvé qu'il est un organe
politique est pas une institution
judiciaire le tribunal ignore les
véritables crimes de guerre et poursuit
à la place l'état d'israël un état avec
un régime démocratique solide qui
sanctifie l'état de droit et n'est pas
un membre du tribunal et on en a parlé
avec françois costantini les
géopolitologue je pense que c'est
uniquement de façon symbolique un appel
à la juridiction pénale internationale
qui a voulu faire l'autorité
palestinenne là dessus elle a marqué un
point mais on peut tout à fait sans
s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait sur le
terrain et de façon effective
aucune enquête qui se déroule israël
peut objecter en effet qui n'est pas
signataire qui ne meurent sous qui n'est
pas impliquée en effet par la cpi alors
que les statuts de la cpi prévoit en
effet qu on peut aller au delà des des
seuls signataires et ils objectera bien
sûr que le l'enquète n'a pas lieu d'être
et comme j'ai dit il faut s'attendent en
effet à ce que les juges soient
vraisemblement bloqué lors de leur
entrée dans les territoires palestiniens
puisqu'il faut passer par israël pour
entrer dans les territoires palestiniens